قال وزير الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد بن
عبد الرحمن ال ثاني ان المبررات المقدمه
لمقطعه مونديال قطر لا تستند الى
الموضوعيه مشيرا الى وجود كثير من النفاق
في الهجمات التي تستهدف بلاده والتي
تتجاهل كل الانجازات التي حققتها اضاف في
مقابله مع صحيفه الفرنسيه
الى ان اكثر من 97% من التذاكر بيعه ومن
بين الدول العشر التي اشتركت
اشترت اكبر عدد من التذاكر هناك دول
اوروبيه
قال ان كره القدم من كل الجميع وليست
محجوده لنادي
450 مليون عربيه مسرورون لان كاس العالم
واشار الى ان كل ما تطلبه قطر هو ان يحترم
وشجعونا قوانين البلد واشار الى ان قطر
قطعت شوطا كبيرا من اجل تغيير تشريعاتها
لكنه لا فتى الا ان اصلاح نظام العملي
يتطلب وقتا وقال ان هناك ثغرات لا تزال
موجوده لكن قطر عازمه على اصلاحها لكن
وزير الخارجيه القطريه تساءل لماذا تنسب
تلك المشاكل للحكومه فقط بينما في اوروبا
عندما يقع اي حادث تحمل المؤسسه وزر ذلك
واصفا هذا الامر بانه سياسه الكيل بمكيلين
واعرض عن اعتقاده بان بعض الاشخاص لا
يقبلون ان يستضيف بلد صغير من الشرق
الاوسط وينظم حدثا كونيا مثل بطوله العالم